what's up everyone welcome back to
collider's interview Studio of fantastic
Fest 2023 I'm so excited to finally meet
and talk to Joe Lynch in person
especially for suitable flesh you have a
trio of some of my favorite working
actors in this movie doing some really
fun stuff I feel the same way believe me
it's it's amazing to like sit there and
go they're in my movie like and together
and doing that that and that and oh oh
thato yeah but trust me like I every day
on set was and and I've been blessed
with having amazing actors in my films
but this one in
particular especially on the first day
of filming because there is a particular
scene uh that is a a love making scene I
don't want to say it's a sex scene um
how are we on rating board here like how
many uh I say you go for it you say what
you want as my only rule is no spoilers
but otherwise other you give no
yes I have dropped an F bomber two on
this channel over the years of course
the editor logging this right now going
son of a Lynch Jesus well uh my
first day on set our first day on set
was uh let's see we had Heather Graham
and Jonathan Sheek and Judah Lewis and
I've been a fan of theirs I've worked
with one of them in Jonathan and Creep
Show but I never worked with Heather and
Judah before and they were all in bed
together I'm not giving anything away or
am I but to watch them all even just
sitting there practically naked talking
about
tro was an absolute trip and then I'm
going like I'm sorry guys we got to go
back to one and do this again that those
are the sort of moments that you cherish
on a set and you pray that like that it
also translates on film because you're
sitting there going like is it hot in
here woo and then you you know you watch
the footage and go like yes in fact it
was hot in there for everyone involved
but at the same time making it so that
everyone is comfortable and safe and
having fun and everybody was like in it
which is great which is always helpful
um but yeah like just having that cast
there every day was a pure joy because
they were very invested yes you need to
be I'm going to come back to that but
first just in case anyone out there does
not know what suitable flesh is about
also because I like the filmmaker to do
this so I know where to draw the line on
spoilers can you give everyone a brief
synopsis of your movie I'm the worst
person to do that because I'll take
about 97 minutes to go through the whole
thing but I've gotten better with this I
knew that we were going to talk and I
knew that we had to have the
encapsulated version
So based on the HP Lovecraft Story the
thing on the doorstep suitable flesh
concerns a popular and very well-to-do
psychologist uh Elizabeth Derby who one
day meets a young man a very troubled
young man who comes into her office with
uh with an issue or or two or four and
uh thus starts a a descent into hell
Madness sexual identity gender fluids
other fluids and uh Cosmic body body
swapping a little bit of cthulu and
everything that you'd want out of a NE
neotica horror love story you were not
kidding you came in this room prepared
for that that all came off the
top of my head extremely imp as someone
who has planned to a tea and can't
deviate I am very impressed right now
we've we've been doing this the the tour
for the movie you know as I've lovingly
called the pr at Tribeca at Tribeca
we've been calling it the flesh devil
tour the flesh devil tour my marketing
skills are on par um but having done
this a few times I still like there's so
much the reason why I wanted to make
this movie was there's and this is very
indicative of this Festival is there
there is nothing better than to watch a
movie and whether you want it to wash
over you or not but to watch a movie and
then have a conversation not just yeah
that rocked oh that Superhero ruled you
know like just to be able to have a
discussion whether it's the movie itself
whether the movie Sparks a discussion
about honestly there's so many things
about this movie that we specifically
infused with like gender identity and
the female gays and you know why can't
women be sexy you know at a certain age
you know the fear of Desire the
consequence of Desire sexual fluidity
all of these things were just things
that I wanted to talk about outside of
the Alamo afterwards on other people's
movies and lately you know I haven't
been here but it's been there's been a
uh a drought of these kind of movies and
I wanted to bring them back into the
discussion it does feel like this
particular year of the festival not that
I this is my first fantastic Fest but
this Festival feels especially rich with
content that Sparks those kinds of
conversations after the fact it's been a
moist Festival you know both outside and
inside I'd say can can confirm there I
can think of a lot of other
inappropriate terms to describe the
films that I've seen I've already broken
the seal that is what fantastic Fest is
for exactly I was reading that this
script went through a little bit of an
evolution so can you pinpoint the thing
that changed the most from draft one to
finished film 100% uh I in in getting
the script from Barbara krampton and
when you get a script from Barbara
kampton and you read that it's from the
writer of reanimator and from Beyond and
you see that it is an adaptation of HP
Lovecraft you you you perk up your ears
you don't delete that email and um at
the time I was starting to work with my
writing partner uh Becca and when we
started reading the script she was um
she was in another country at the time
because of the pandemic and when we were
going back and forth on it we both both
emailed each other at the same time
hours apart going what about this and
you know if you know the original story
the original story was um it's very Mal
skewed it's two male protagonists and
not that we wanted to especially like
lately where most most producers writers
you know have been like what if we
gender swap this what if it's Lethal
Weapon with chicks and you know there
has to be a point to it it can't just be
grasping for a new demo or going like
we're going to be Progressive there was
something that both of us when we
thought about that idea that it just it
created the spark that made me so
excited to tell this movie like not just
the fact that it was kind of getting the
Baton from Stuart Gordon who was the
original director on this it wasn't just
the fact that I'd be able to work with
you know the like Dennis and Barbara and
Brian it was
specifically I want to make this movie
dangerous I want to make this movie
because like I myself am I think all of
us have been challenging our own sexual
identity in the past couple years and I
wanted to explore that and that like
once we came up with that idea honestly
I thought Barbara and Dennis were going
to be like no hard pass but we we sent
them an eight page like the thesis paper
on why we should go this route whether
or not they liked it you know that that
was kind of up to them but then Dennis
came back three weeks later with a new
draft immediately that you know that
evolved from there but it wasn't just
that he changed the names from like
Edward to Elizabeth he saw the potential
of what you can do with a body swap
movie in a lovecraftian kind of form but
doing in a way that felt fresh and
different and again and dangerous too
yes all the right keywords and Barbara
clearly liked it enough that she's not
just a producer on this film she's also
a star she was not supposed to be in the
movie up until the last moment I've read
that somewhere and I'm like like I'm
sure there's many other talented actors
who could have crushed the role but
Barbara in that role is absolutely
perfect when we were when we were
rewriting the script I kept thinking
this would be perfect for Barbara but
she said right from the from the jump
she's like I just want to be behind the
scenes I want to make sure everybody's
you know happy she's the best producer
on set she's making sure that
everybody's happy she's going to the
grips going like can I get you water
are you hungry she's like the the den
mother for everybody on set and it and
it's great because it it adds a very
positive vibe but then she's also got to
act in it and I think she wanted to take
a step back like when she was doing that
movie glorious she really liked being
behind the scenes and it wasn't until we
had like the draft right before we shot
where I
went ready
Babs babe come on you know like it it
was uh it was it took a little
convincing at first but the second that
she said okay fine maybe I think she
needed us to just goat her on a little
bit but the second that she said
yes
it it it everything codified you know
because the dynamic between these two
women the thing that I was
so um focused on in terms of that
relationship because no matter what
whether it's women or men that
relationship between um Derby and um uh
Danny and Daniela they need to be they
need to feel like friends so we came up
with like all these little things that
they would do like little catchphrases
you know the fact that their favorite
movie was white Christmas you know and
there's that song Sisters you know like
we even cut the we wrote that into the
script at one point and then at the very
end they went we can't afford that so we
found another song but there were all
these little details to enhance their
relationship that was beyond the page
that I always feel like sometimes when
you write it into a script it it feels
forced whereas we made sure that you
know Heather and Barbara were friends
before they even stepped on set and what
was great was that I also had a producer
Barbara who was like we need to hang out
let's go for wine and I'm like yes you
should go go for wine and cheese you
know you calling her the onset Den
mother feels so appropriate obviously
I've never worked with her on making a
film but even just being a member of the
horror Community it feels like she has a
very similar place in that space as well
where she makes everybody feel welcome
and warm whether you're like a big fan
and you're nervous to meet her or you're
a collaborator she just I don't know she
treats everybody equally and she
celebrates and uplifts everyone and I'll
never stop appreciating that I think one
of the things that Barbara one of the
smartest things that Barbara did was
these wise words that uh a great poet
Bobcat gowe told me once was whenever
you've don't feel into it anymore quit
just if your heart's not into it anymore
get out
stop becoming bitter over the process
because of opportunities not coming your
way because the creative process isn't
the way that you wanted to you know to
achieve and Barbara for a Time said I'm
done so she moved up north and she you
know like uh cultivated a family a
beautiful family and then it wasn't
until Adam Wingard called her up and
said hey do you want to do this and she
had felt like at that point that no one
like thought about her for these kind of
roles anymore and it was Simon and Adam
who said we want you to be in your next
which that's a fantastic Fest alumnus
yep and from there I think she found the
spark again and she like the thing that
I love about Barbara is that she is yes
she is the den mother to all she's very
smart in terms of the kind of projects
she wants to be involved in like she
doesn't just jump on anything just to be
relevant or just to have new photos for
the next convention or whatever she's
she's cultivating her acting career in a
very smart way but the fact that she's
gotten behind the the screens and become
a producer and a very smart one at that
she has this pulse on the taste of where
har is going and she uses it so well
plus she is just the nicest person on
set offset like she and then she does
the
smile and you can't not love her you
know she she is such a positive force
and it's the kind of POS force that we
need in the genre now more than ever
that is why I always take an opportunity
to put the spotlight on Barbara and how
she influences projects and others I
will say this Barbara is having serious
fomo right now not being able to be here
and and you know we love you Barbara we
support you know why you why you're not
here um it's a shame but um at the same
time we did our Tribeca screening you
know which again the fact that we made
Tribeca was just a huge thing for all of
us cuz that kind kind of legitimizes you
um and the fact that she was able to see
it with all of our friends and even
Dennis showed up um but to see that hard
labor payoff she was thrilled you know
absolutely to continue uh celebrating
your actors here because your your three
leads are un just like Unstoppable in
this movie and it does feel like it's
the type of movie that demands that all
three of them are willing to go
110% in order to make this story work do
the three of them Barbara Heather and
Judah have a shared quality that when
you met them or based on knowing Barbara
convinced you that they will go there
all the time and nothing will hold them
back uh yes all three of them were
absolutely Fearless on set 100% we had a
lot of scenes that um would make any
actor uncomfortable um you know sex
scenes violent scenes blood gore but
funny enough it was the emotional
moments uh it was even just two people
sitting in a room talking which on paper
you know you when you when you're in
production and you see like three pages
of dialogue with no action a lot of
times people go oh we'll just bang
through that but these are actors who
don't want to just bang through it
there's other there's other banging
involved you know but but when it comes
to these moments they took it very
seriously and they were trying things
and again look we were on a very short
uh time we had very little money to make
this work but the creative freedom was
there to allow them to try and you
know considering that this is a movie
about body swapping and all of the
actors had to play different characters
at some point and which was really
exciting so we all got to figure out
like little tells little details things
with hands
catchphrases none of them would have
done that if we if they weren't like you
said 100% % committed I mean I would go
so far as to say 157% committed that's
that's an accurate am that's fair fair
percentage but they were um very much in
tune with each other too they were
texting each other at night going you
know like what if we tried this what
what if that was a word what if we used
the word Dandy you know like I I wrote
that in you know there's a moment where
Dandy gets used and in a way it's it's a
it's a bit of a tell for the audience to
realize like oh okay I know exactly
where everybody is but the biggest part
and I think this is something that um is
indicative of the time is that both
Heather and Barbara have been in films
in the um in the annals of Cinema
history that um have required them to uh
have nudity um to be in sex scenes and
you know Judah has not you know like
that that young boy uh became a man the
first week on set his birthday was
actually like that his 21st birthday was
um the scene when we uh in the basement
where he had to do 32 pages in one day
I've seen all of his work this is
definitely going into different
territory for him and the fact that like
all three of them were completely in
like they were sympatico when it came to
making sure that everyone felt
comfortable so that they could be able
to try new things and and do things that
were a little more on the provocative
side you know and that then it comes
down to me to make sure that everyone
feels safe and comfortable I you know
did storyboards basically showing them
exactly where the camera was going to be
which was unfortunate because it was um
either myself or my partner like having
to take snapshots of ourselves and then
Trace over them and I'm going oh my butt
looks terrible but that'll work you know
but the more that you go in completely
prepared so that they feel comfortable
to explore the better okay I'll follow
up on that because I love hearing about
the unexpected movie Magic that happens
on set even when you plan plan plan some
of the unplanned stuff winds up being
the best so can you pinpoint a day on
set when you veered from those story
boards and you found unexpected magic
that was even better than what you had
originally planned uh yes um so there is
uh a scene in the movie uh they they're
like two little scenes but we we've
bunched them together we we call it and
I know you'll get this immediately the
uh the Smashing and the stabbing know
exactly what you're talking about
the Smashing part was something that I
had in my back pocket for 15 years I've
wanted to do that since I owned a Prius
and that's all I'm going to say but
hopefully if you when you see the movie
you will never look at that again the
same way which is great I've I've always
shocked no one has done that I mean
maybe there's something that I've missed
I believe me I've been watching a lot of
movies praying that that would never
happen in a movie the way that we tried
to do it someone will copy you now and
it will be then it'll be a jool I'm
sorry and you're welcome uh 10% to my
agent um but the the second part of it
the
stabbing that was also very um directly
storyboarded out and everything but
because we spent so much time on trying
to get the smash ining part right and we
only had one night in that location um
we had 30 minutes to get everything all
my hoyy toyy Brian DePalma shots for the
the stabbing part and and I realized I'm
screwed I don't have there's no way that
I can get any of what I need so uh we
set up the first shot and it did not go
well at all uh Pro tip for all you
filmmakers out there and I'll say this
again and again uh when in doubt have a
watermelon in your car why because when
you have someone who's getting stabbed
if they're just doing this it looks like
you're masturbating a ghost it's just
it's just weird like but if you have
something for them to St into it creates
the friction that you need I should stop
doing that it creates the friction no ST
it creates we've crossed that line
already long time ago but it it really
it does create the illusion of um
stabbing into something someone so to
speak and I had to completely come up
with brand new shots we because the sun
was coming up and then we got back and
when we're in in the edit um my editor
and I said what the hell are we going to
do with this and then it was just like I
got kicked out of the booth um like of
the room because we were just not coming
to terms with we have two angles what
the hell are we going to do with this
and then the
editor came up with this thing that you
saw that is like this very weird almost
experimental way of showing this it's
like uh fuli meets uh like unan unalo
and it was never planned that way and
that was because we had the necessity of
we only have 30 minutes we only have two
shots what can you do with that and and
that's happened on every one of my films
like that some just run you just run out
of time and you have to be as creative
as possible in all forms to be able to
make your day but also serve the story
eight plus sequence right there a thank
you I want to keep you here all day to
talk about every sequence that I adore
in this movie I'm not allowed and I
promised you I'd end with one specific
done we have to wind down yeah I want I
want to keep you here but we also have a
whole bunch of other movies to celebrate
which kind of align it does align with
the last question that I wanted to pitch
to you cuz you said you've seen a bunch
of movies here at Fantastic p and this
is my first year here I have it is which
is wild to me I've always wanted to come
here but this is finally the year that
Happ wait hold on this is my part so
Perry how has your fantastic Fest been
so my fantastic Fest is absolutely
phenomenal because it's lived up to all
the expectations and I have the feeling
that like I'm home I'm home with a whole
bunch of genre lovers that not only want
to go and see the movie themselves but
support the other people in this
community so given that can you pinpoint
something you've seen in a movie that's
playing here that made you go like damn
that is something else and I can't
believe you pulled that off oh I can
name it right off the bat and it was the
opening night movie it was The Toxic
Avenger because that movie should have
never happened uh it felt like it felt
dangerous it felt like the movies that I
loved as a kid that I wasn't supposed to
watch
or movies that just felt so offbeat
there was a term back in the day kids
that they used offbeat whenever you talk
about like a conen Brothers movie
because they were just they were skewing
differently and they didn't give a
whether or not you like adhere to it
eventually you get to it what monan did
with that movie was so unparalleled to
what I expected cuz you like I was very
close with the the project I was going
to I was up for it at one point I like I
was The Toxic Avenger at troma at one
point I have receipts um so I went into
it you know like CU I love Mon's work
but I was also a little skeptical and I
walked out of that thing so happy
because it beats to its own drum and
movies don't do that anymore like if you
think of movies like freaked or super um
Super Mario Brothers in a way the old
one you know the these are movies love
that movie I you know what I mean like
there's there's very few chances these
days especially with an IP like that
done on a studio level that you have the
resources to World build no one's doing
that right now or not many movies or not
enough movies are doing that and what
Meg was able to do with the World
building but at the same time still make
it a trauma movie that blew me the
away uh Becca was with me that night and
she just cuz the whole time she's just
walking around going this is what
fantastic Fest is I'm like yes you are
spoiled now but but that is like the
perfect like introduction to the
Fantastic Fest experience that I've had
every single time I've come here from
2007 with Wrong Turn 2 to Everly and
then this one the evolution of it it's
never lost its Edge and that's why we
come here but also never lost its Edge
and you still feel like you're hanging
out with all of your cool cousins on a
Friday night drinking beers and watching
as many movies as possible so so true
this has been the ideal atmosphere thus
far and it just keeps getting better and
better
especially when I get to see a movie
like yours it really is something else
huge congratulations to everybody out
there do not miss suitable flesh it's
going to get
fleshy